هناك الملايين من الطرق التي
يمكن للناس أن يتصرفوا بها على نحو مستدام ،
لكن هل يمكن لملايين الأشخاص أن يقرروا القيام
بذلك في نفس الوقت ،
التغيير الجذري هو شيء
عليك القيام به مع أشخاص
من المدينة ، أعتقد أن
معظم الناس في أمستردام لديهم  الأرواح
لإحداث هذا التغيير تمتلك أمستردام
طموحًا
كبيرًا لتصبح أول مدينة دائرية بالكامل في العالم
بحلول عام 2050
مما يعني القضاء على جميع النفايات
بحيث يتم إعادة تدوير كل شيء يتم إلقاؤه هنا إلى شيء جديد ، نعم
طموح كبير ، فكيف يمكنك إخراج هذا
من
اقتصاد الكعك المحلى  بقلم كيت برايوود
أوم دونات اقتصاديات الدونات ، يبدو الأمر
سخيفًا ، لكنها طريقة جادة ومرحة
لتخيل الرخاء البشري
كيت خبيرة اقتصادية مشهورة ، دعني
أعرضك على كعكة الدونات التي
قد تكون في الواقع جيدة بالنسبة
لنا
، لقد طورت دونات
كبديل  للرأسمالية وتقول إنها
يمكن أن تساعدنا في تحقيق الاستدامة ،
لذا فإن الفكرة هي أننا نريد ألا نترك
أحدًا في الحفرة في وسط
الكعكة  هذا هو المكان الذي يفتقر فيه الناس
إلى أساسيات
الحياة ، حيث لا يتوفر للناس
طعام ، ماء ، تعليم ، رعاية صحية ، دخل إسكان ،
يحتاج كل شخص إلى
موارد الأرض لتلبية احتياجاته الأساسية ،
ولكن في نفس الوقت لا يمكننا
استخدام موارد الأرض بشكل جماعي في
بهذه الطريقة
نتخطى الحدود ونبدأ في
تحطيم أنظمة دعم
الحياة لمنزلنا الكوكبي لأن هذا هو
المكان الذي نتسبب فيه في انهيار المناخ ،
لذا فإن هدف المتبرع هو تلبية
احتياجات جميع الناس
ضمن وسائل الكوكب الحي
تقول كيت إن الهدف
من التواجد داخل الكعك يجب أن
يحل محل الأهداف الاقتصادية التقليدية
التي يمكن أن ينموها الناتج المحلي الإجمالي للدولة ، لكن
الأشخاص ذوي الأجور المنخفضة والمتوسطة لا
يرون
أيًا من ذلك يأتي في جيوبهم ، لذلك
نحن بحاجة إلى مقاييس أكثر ثراءً
لتخبرنا أن الجميع
حياة مزدهرة يقول بعض النقاد إنها مثالية للغاية
ولكن بعد ضرب covet 19 ، أخذت أمستردام
الفكرة بالكامل
عندما تكون في أزمة عميقة
aybe هي أفضل لحظة للتفكير في
مستقبل أكثر
إشراقًا ونعلم أنه يتعين علينا تغيير عالمنا
من أجل الحفاظ على كوكبنا
آمنًا ولكي نصبح مجتمعًا شاملاً
وعادلاً
لجعل الناس داخل مدينة الكعك ، يتعامل
قادة المدينة مع الإيجارات المرتفعة و
بدأوا بإهدار الطعام من خلال بناء أحياء خالية من
الانبعاثات مع
إسكان
اجتماعي ووجدوا طرقًا لهؤلاء السكان
لشراء بقايا طعام منخفضة التكلفة من المطاعم القريبة
التي كان من الممكن أن تضيع
ولضمان أن المدينة لا تتجاوز
حدود الكعك ،
تطلب أمستردام أحدًا من  أكبر
صناعاتها لمساعدة
العديد من الناس غير مدركين لحقيقة أن
الدنيم هو في
الواقع عمل تجاري كبير هنا في أمستردام ، لذا فإن
ما يعنيه ذلك للناس في جميع أنحاء
العالم هو أن
العديد من الجينز الذي يشتريه الناس
ويرتدونه في متاجرهم
محليًا مصمم بالفعل و  نشأت هنا
في أمستردام
جيمس وشاركت في تأسيس بيت الدنيم في أمستردام
وهي مؤسسة مكرسة
للتعليم والابتكار المستدام.
تتطلب البصمة الكربونية للتجارة التي
تجعل زوجًا واحدًا من الجينز
7000 لترًا من المياه وفقًا
لأرقام الصناعة
، ولهذا السبب تعاون جيمس وقادة المدن
مع 35 علامة تجارية
وموردًا لتكوين صفقة الدنيم
، والتزامًا بإنتاج 3 مليارات قطعة
ملابس مع 20
مادة معاد تدويرها في غضون عامين
من المثير
للاهتمام أن الجين الذي يحتوي على 20 قطنًا معاد التدوير فيه
يوفر 750 لترًا من الماء في
جميع أنحاء عالم الدنيم ، كلنا
أردنا تأثيرًا أقل ،
ولكننا نطلب من
كل فرد في السلسلة
إجراء التغيير بشكل فردي وهذا
هو أساس
العلامات التجارية لصفقات الدنيم مثل سكوتش و  صودا كالفن
كلاين وتومي هيلفيغر قفزوا جميعًا على
متن الطائرة
وقريبًا ستطلب المدينة أيضًا من
السكان المساعدة في تقليل نفايات الدنيم من خلال
إنشاء سلسلة من ورش الإصلاح
ونقاط تجميع إعادة التدوير